ja ich bin ja nicht nur kabarettist
sondern auch begeisterter koch muss ich
wirklich sagen und das war natürlich
toll jetzt in der korona zeit wo man
nicht ins restaurant gehen hat können
habe das wunderbare sachen gemacht und
endlich kommen wir wieder freunde zum
essen einladen und das mache ja wirklich
immer ganz ausgiebig das land die
freunde seien alle da und dann wird
gekocht aber doch nicht an krone und
spinat batzen auf den tisch und sagte
ich scheiß mikrowelle
nein da werden gänge menüs werden da
aufgetischt und die kriegt da muss ich
tatsächlich sehr viel lob kriege da
immer von den gästen und immer aber das
nicht im bus hochgejubelt wird verstehen
dass mit alison das war super und das
war nur besser und es war nur viel viel
besser es morgen nicht weil das hilft
mir nichts übrig so wenn irgendetwas
nicht so gut war dann möchte ich daran
die rückmeldung haben weil nur dann kann
man lernen man kann nur durch kritik
lehrern ist also niemand was durch lobt
gelernt verstehen dass mir und und darum
war es kurzer freund von mir war da und
dieser sehr ehrlicher mensch sehr gerade
raus wo sie wirklich sehr sehr schätze
und der hat nach dem essen gesagt
also es war super günther wie immer
fantastisch aber eine frage hätte ich
bei der soße war doch kümmel drin sagt
ja ja da war kümmel drin oder sagt
will's wissen bei kümmel mag er jetzt
nicht so gerne
exakt johannes dick ich hasse kreml der
typ der jemals kümmel als gewürz
eingeführt hat der kehrt heiko und wand
stellen
nur gesagt ja das empfindet er genauso
aber warum durften dann gesagt bitte was
wieso warum du hast dann sage ich weiß
im rezept drin gestanden ist sagte also
ja aber er hat nicht nur seine
entschuldigung bin ist im rezept darin
steht dann muss ich durch den krümeln
sopera er macht sowie irgendwas neben
auch was im gesetz steht dass nicht leid
und tod etwas niveau sein mag das ok hat
dann brauche ich aber durch ko rezept
oder da dann nimm doch einfach alles was
magst hause in einen topf und den
steilen und fertig das muss noch lange
da brauche ich doch co rezept sagte er
das versteht doch irgendwie versteht
diene der herrschaftszeit noch mal wenn
es draufsteht im rezeptur ist doch nie
hätte dies hatte doch ausgedacht dieses
rezept ist hat er durch durch versuch
und irrtum jahrelang jahrzehntelang hat
der an diesem rezept gearbeitet geld und
nichts sagt lohner hallen und kümmel
schmeckt zwar scheiße ist aber durch mir
wurscht sparen muss sein sprach
wallenstein und schubia her auch wieder
rein
dies sorgt noch der nicht die hause
gedanken macht sein koch dieser künstler
statt der durch diese rezept nicht
verändern
ich gehe doch nicht ins museum
brandschaden analyse hatte er eine
etappe die fresse für kommunale rossmann
und neuere mit edding april in schicken
und einen schnurrbart und große
überlassen
das mache ich doch gar nicht da sich der
maler von der mona lisa der mann für die
tür der das ist aber gedanken der sagen
war grünwald wieder da der vortest der
pläne wir bauen die mona lisa
aufeinander
jetzt habe ich schon sechsmal habe die
mona lisa gemacht die trompeterin wollte
und wieder um einander oder meinen
bieten den handys so schöne betende
hände kunde er macht handschellen hin
das geht nicht mein hase der schönste
hase der himmels gemalt worden ist jedes
haar vor dem fell hobby 19
verstehst günter grünwald mir so lange
herum bis auf ihre meerschweinchen
ich hoffe das wird vom künstler nicht
verändern und genauso ist bei einem
rezept darf ich nicht verändern kunde er
ist mein essen und rät daher oder doch
der horror fressen der blöde und der
blöde wenig wo zum essen eingeladen
werden sowie das war sehr gut das war
besser und das war noch viel viel besser
so jetzt ist es doch blöd naja gibt
schlimmeres vielen dank
[Musik]